first of all congratulations on your
most recent performance
the last time i talked to you you had
just performed shallow by lady gaga you
impressed the judges so much
how did this new performance feel for
you how did it
feel second time up there well it
definitely felt even more exciting
because i got to see the judges again
and this time it was at universal
studios so it is a great experience
to uh see where all these great movies
are filmed and tv shows
and it's just an amazing uh experience
it's a great place to be
so i'm really lucky
okay so how did it feel performing
you say by lauren daigle how did that
whole performance feel up on stage
well that song every time i sing it it
gives me lots of strength and faith
um you know i also think it sends a lot
of power to people
and a great message lots of great
messages saying you know always have
faith in yourself always believe in
yourself
um you know and i feel like in this song
um you know i'm connecting with so many
things and i hope other people can
connect to that song as well
so it's an amazing song and i'm pretty
sure other people think
i think that as well and i've received a
lot of great comments
saying that they like the song choice
and i'm happy they did because that's
what i would like to transmit
love and peace
and lauren herself she actually reposted
it
and she reached out to me yes she posted
it on her story and she made
an actual post saying um that i crushed
the song
and that was so amazing because you know
getting that um shout out from a
a great singer she's so talented it's it
just feels amazing and i'm
so grateful for her
okay so we need to talk about how the
judges reacted they reacted
very strongly to you sofia vergara
said that you hold a special place in
her heart she said
i want you to win you have howie mandel
who's saying i think you can
you know take this whole season how did
it feel to get that reaction from the
judges
well it felt so unexpected to go to the
same finals but
even to get those were those special
remarks from the judges because
getting those um uh i mean hearing their
thoughts
and their their thoughts like i mean
were great i it was so amazing to hear
their thoughts
and especially kelly clarkson when she
said um you know i
i had a great tone and beautiful tone um
it really i find her as a an influencer
for me and a big idol for me
because in a big role model as well
because she's a singer and i'm a singer
and it gives me a lot of um a lot of
strength and it
boosts a lot of courage in me and i'm so
grateful that
um i they all had such amazing remarks